welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question it's the show that
gives you too much information about how
the various spider-man movies have
actually been quietly referencing each
other from the beginning setting up a
live-action spider-verse
where we will see which Peter Parker is
the stickiest going on in
I'm Erik Bosse here with me in the first
time for a big question off screen
producers that Huddleston and I think
now we should start going you on screen
producer you know what Eric
off screen is more a state of mind off
screens Zacks gonna handle the big
question for us this week because you
know we've been going back through the
Sam Raimi spider-man movies on the
channel lately going from spider-man
apart from home we realize there's some
crazy connections that we didn't really
see before so Zach my question for you
is how are all the spider-man movies
connected in a live-action spider-verse
yes and this has been a hot topic of
conversation recently right there's a
couple things that are going to come up
shortly
you know the Morbius trailer and into
the spider-verse animated movie that Sam
Raimi being the director for Doctor
Strange - there's all these kind of
things that are leading a lot of people
to speculate like could we get a
live-action spider-verse
is there already a live-action
spider-verse so I'm learning too you can
see this board behind me this is
actually not my research support for
this project I'm pitching a remake of
David Lynch's dune not the upcoming de
Villanueva or whatever this is just I
just want to recut oh they scooped you
yeah but I'm basically I'm getting out
the red yarn but in this case the red
yarn is sweet quit is it gonna be a
spider webs yes did you feel that do you
ever felt it oh yeah I died was a real
off-screen twit there and so we're going
to try to flip our way through the
spider verse first to kind of lay out
the different universes we're going to
be connecting so the the big ones that
we're gonna be talking about of course
there's the the original Sam Raimi Tobey
Maguire trilogy spider-man one two and
three and and we're not gonna use this
number a lot but for for the eggheads
out there that's earth 9 6 to 8 3 is
kind of the Marvel designation they
doesn't made all their different
timelines and universes right so that's
a big one obviously the current one the
Tom Holland MCU timeline right he's
showing up in Avengers movie
showing up in his own solo films that is
earth one nine nine nine nine nine five
nines right and that also encompasses
the entire MCU the Iron Man movies Thor
everything now and this is where it's
it's already gonna get weird here but
there's a separate adjunct universe for
the spider-man villain movies yeah
they're kind of connected but we don't
really know how exactly yeah and I'm
like back in I like the term adjunct cuz
it both makes me sound professorial but
also Amy Pascal at Sony used that term
when describing kind of these movies in
an interview with like Kevin Feige back
in like 2017 before venom came out so
like it seems like it kind of works like
they're technically adjacent to the MCU
they don't um contradict anything in the
MCU that they also don't necessarily
like they're not showing up in each
other's movies yet right spider-man is
yet to be in a venom movie though that
that might change we'll talk about that
in a second so that that is earth one
nine nine nine nine nine nine adjunct or
earth TRN six eight eight is the kind of
technical name that's the Marvel
designation yes yeah yeah I love I love
the term at times can I just talk they
know this because I think to me that's
like Amy Pascal as Dwight Schrute and
like it's not like I'm the assistant to
the regional universe I can't imagine
this place without you they're like yeah
yeah it's like this is my universe too
right yeah I'll just hang out at this
party and before anyone notices me Nixon
yeah they're just so desperate to be in
the like same zip code as the MCU later
during Woodstock Amy Pascal was in
Buffalo and so she's like I was
basically you know speaking of shout out
Bill's army I sent to me by a fan mark
shout out shout out Tommy Beto Bills
Bills on me everywhere okay but back to
the list so then we have the
specifically the film animated universe
that has it right now just has into the
spider verse one right there's a lot of
other TV shows that are animated movies
things like that but we're just talking
about that into the spider verse Miles
Morales animated universe
earth TRN 700 which is actually kind of
an adaptation of the comics Ultimates
universe earth 1610 yeah it's kind of
confusing cuz within that universe they
show the different like spider versus
you have spider hams University of penny
Parker's University of Earth 1610 and I
think you have the original six one six
in there that's all kind of contained
within this corner yeah that it's just
miles is universe right is the is the
one we're kind of talking about he could
technically connect to all these other
ones but like his kind of base level is
earth TRN 700 or whatever and then
continuing we have the Andrew Garfield
amazing spider-man 1 and 2 yes that
happened earth 1 2 0 703 it also has
like the least coherent number and then
also kind of the video game world and
there's been a lot of different
spider-man video games this is we're
mostly gonna focus on the most recent
ps4 video game that a lot of people
loved and played right and maybe then
also connect to the upcoming PS 5 yeah
the Miles Morales one yeah things we're
not gonna be trying to connect right
obviously the original comics which you
know there's tons of comics connections
to all of this work right it's kind of
all the bases the 60s animated TV show
the 70s live-action TV show Japanese
spider-man any kind of recent Disney XD
or something you know we're not gonna
think about that just things that have
come out as as films okay wait so you're
not gonna do the Universal Studios
Islands of Adventure ride that's not
gonna tie in debt legit made me bark and
I'm not I'm not talking about Quentin
Beck's technology I'm talking about the
stuff that comes out of your mouth when
you get motion sickness so we've
established our six universes now the
connections kind of between these
universes in the ways that these
universes reference each other right and
kind of the most important one the text
of spider-man films is that Sam Raimi
trilogy
right it was kind of the first big
screen appearance of spider-man
everything that's come after that it's
kind of a reference to that even when
it's technically a comic book reference
it's really a reference to Sam Raimi's
comic book reference they looms just so
large in our pop culture
psyche they're either borrowing from it
or responding to it you know
yes like well they already did it that
way so now we're gonna do it this way
and the biggest one kind of one that's
on the top of a lot of our minds since
spider-man far from home JK Simmons as
Jay jonah Jameson speech a menace to the
entire city
JK jonah Jameson he played that role in
the original trilogy and we see him in
the post credit scene or mid-credits
scene and far from home riot is this
kind of new Alex Jones style Jay jonah
jameson breaking the news of Peter
Parker's real identity and so like
that's clearly a connection right you
don't pass the exact same actor in the
exact same role unless you want there to
be like a direct reference right and
you've pointed out your videos Eric
they're like well here's a slightly
different take on the character we don't
know that he's the exact same Jay jonah
jameson but it does seem like obviously
that's what they're aiming for there's a
rumor that he is gonna show up in that
role in the Morbius movie which would be
really bad because we're already with
connecting MCU to Raimi verse right but
that would connect MCU to Raimi verse
Raimi verse to villain verse right which
we don't have a direct connection
between those yet and also it seems like
there was some kind of like Spider Man
hate sin that graffiti right and the
Morbius trailer maybe that could be what
that's referring to people were just
whipped up by uh by Alex Jones hey jonah
jameson yes right it's it murderer is
scrawled on the spider-man poster in the
background as Morbius is running down an
alley and you know there's no other
reason that we know of in the Morbius
universe that people would be calling
spider-man a murderer right other than
Jay Jonah kind of outing him for the
death of Mysterio Mysterio kind of
planting that right so it seems like
that that's going to be a direct
connection between the Morbius kind of
villain verse and the MCU Tom Holland
spider-verse I'm gonna be making fun
hand motions for all of these
connections
speaking of Raimi verse connections
right we have one of the best because
I'm a professional wrestling fan so bone
saw McGraw who's the character that
Macho Man Randy Savage rest in peace
Randy Poffo played in the original
spider-man
and that should upon the kind of the
subtext of a wrestling poster in far
from home that's right
same guy exists about and that was an
original thing like they had crusher
Hogan on that poster who's from the
comics but like they turned crusher
Hogan into boats um aground the Raimi
movie there's an original creation for
the rainy verse that is also now in the
MCU that's pretty wild again maybe
that's just a lot of these you could
easily write off as like these are just
like the art department when to sneak in
little reference but of course that's
not fun it's much more fun to be like
Randy Savage existed in this world with
Tom Holland and Nick Fury and everything
else
speaking of which right like maybe the
iconic moment from the first fighter man
movie and just like an indelible part of
pop culture now the upside-down kiss
right like that is maybe like the thing
people picture when they picture those
rainy movies and everybody's tried to
recreate it too much awkward effect okay
a couple people probably have
concussions out there from attempting
their own upside and so that has shown
up almost everywhere right obviously it
originated in rainy verse but then in
the animated Peter B Parker references
that you see I saved the city fell in
love right like we see that was yeah
origin of his relationship with MJ right
Mary Jane right they recreate that kiss
its teased in spider-man homecoming kiss
her they don't end up kissing but that
was clearly a reference to that so does
Karen know about the Raimi vs. yes she's
seen the Raimi movies you know there was
another one that I spotted when we went
back through far from home when Peter
kisses MJ on Tower Bridge in London
there's a car that's flipped over next
to them that has the license plate
number it's like a SM 143 which is the
issue where Peter man kisses MJ but the
car is upside down so I feel like that's
also a possible reference to like the
upside down kiss like MJ they don't kiss
upside down but the car is that's
referencing their kiss like why flip the
car you know am i stretch it is that a
slip is it a reef yeah good I mean I'm
I'm being very generous with my Swift
okay rips meet in the middle so then a
few other recent MCU references to the
rainy verse write you among other people
have pointed out when Peters packing for
Europe right his suitcase says BFP a
reference to probably Uncle Ben right
Ben F Parker yeah Ben Parker that dude
party he parties and he dies just like
John Lennon and Jim Morrison and all the
greats by like we haven't seen a Ben
Parker in the current MCU iteration
right like we haven't seen an Uncle Ben
so it's like well maybe we're just too
that's the image we still have in our
mind of that original actor right from
the first spider-man movie yeah no one's
thinking of Martin Sheen okay poor
Martin Sheen in Sally Field right she
was Aunt May in those two movies I mean
great actors great actors throughout
those movies it's just we know for
another quick sidenote from Florida that
will definitely be cut out of this
episode it's always hard to be the
middle right like the middle between two
greats is like the worst possible spot
and I'm thinking specifically of Ron
Zook and this is for all my deep floors
football fans the most famous like
Florida football coach of all times this
guy Steve Spurrier and then the next
most famous was this guy Urban Meyer and
then in between them was this guy Ron
Zook who was a font he was fine he was
an okay coach right but people and he
went on to do some great stuff yeah he
went to Illinois had that upset against
Ohio State that was yes big time still
working as of the most recent and I fell
season by the way um but like between
those two Giants you'll always look like
an ant you know what I mean
and so it is like those amazing
spider-man movies because the rainy ones
are so beloved and so kind of like
historically important and the Tom hunt
and see--you ones are so great on their
own like you're always gonna pale in
comparison yeah thank you for putting it
and in Florida talk maybe you notice I'm
drinking and that's Florida Gators a cup
of water
I carry swamp water with me everywhere
it's our Bobby Boucher water every every
Florida graduate has to carry a little
vial of it automatic it's mostly algae
and it's every bottle of Gatorade as we
call no Powerade in Florida it's the og
yeah its Gatorade or it's nothing okay
and so then another kind of series of
trips right are all centered around
Donald Glover I like right there was
kind of that big campaign as the
recasting spider-man after Toby and the
Raimi
you know crew moved on there was this
kind of fan campaign to get Donald
Glover cast as spider-man it was kind of
concurrent with the debut of Miles
Morales in the comics and so you know he
didn't end up getting cast they went
with intra Garfield pants but because of
that there's all these like Donald
Glover threads now throughout the
spider-verse right like there's a very
tiny cameo in amazing spider-man 1 on
the wall behind into Garfield when he's
in his dorm room I think there's a
donald glover community poster where
he's just like kind of like it's just
down on glover which doesn't mean much
but you could assume that okay great
that could have been aaron davis right
which is what we get in
spider-man homecoming right donald
glover is cast as anna davis uncle to
miles morales right so that is an MCU
flip to the animated universe and is
this connective tissue with miles there
yeah even though like homecoming came
out before into the spider-verse but
they're now connected via this aaron
davis donald glover
character yeah and in into the spider
verse there was a shot of donald glover
as Troy in the spider
man pajamas on that errand Davis's TV
set so like that definitely exists so
through that community connection that
ties in for sure to the animated
absolutely right and that was kind of
the genesis of all of this Donald Glover
shows up in spider-man pajamas in an
episode of community and that led to the
fan campaign and everything else right
so it's like a perfect like 360 complete
circle of reference there are our big
spider-verse web is really starting to
come together it's actually looking like
a real web map yeah a dragonfly is
capable of getting caught in it right
now
I don't know that small bugs I don't
know that it's tight enough that small
bugs will get caught but some larger
insects yeah the big dumb dragonflies
there Doug oh so now I just want to
cover this because like again poor
amazing spider-man those two movies
which are watchable the second one is
kind of rad dawn maybe rightly so but
they're you know whatever they're still
spider-man movies we love those right
they also are kind of the most isolated
right because like subsequent properties
don't really reference them that much
and I think because they they were kind
of the first reboot they didn't want to
reference the Raimi stuff too heavily
either I think they're really thinking
about standing on their own so they're
kind of on an island there's not a ton
of references going in either direction
from those Garfield's Marc Webb movies
except there's a tiny one and it's a
fish-shaped one whip swish in that in
spider-man homecoming Flash Thompson
references branzino and that was not
okay which is a very specific yeah
Mediterranean fish he's in his car on
the way to prom and he's like I know
what branzino should taste like and
that's not it or something like that
right yeah and of course the main other
pop-culture moment of branzino was they
said at nine hundred times in amazing
spider-man 1 when Peter first goes over
to Gwen Stacy's house and has dinner
with her family yeah they're eating
branzino a new york city cop and his
family are eating branzino
they even got some for the kids all
right fYI branzino aka European bass is
a very lovely Mediterranean fish yeah
you know it's it's no tilapia
you're not seeing that on a lot of North
American tables on a regular basis
nikhat you a delicious bass because of
that it stands out right wouldn't have
been the same if it was chicken thing
that they were having so yeah that's it
that's a tiny slip between the MCU and
the Garfield universe they're not tale
of two kitties we can't get to two
kitties to cross over we can find a way
to connect it will do six degrees of
spiders to get to our lasagna lovin
friend you just need a little guidance
that's all in my head cannon tale of two
kitties connects to all movies Tommy
Westfall we're all just specks of dust
on that on that Kitty's paw okay
now we're kind of we're heading into the
the more interesting territory of
connections here specifically the ways
that this weird villain verse connects
to everything right in the big reveal of
that Morbius trailer that came out
before the world shut down right was at
the end of the trailer we see Michael
Keaton as Adrian Toomes right the
vulture sometimes so not only right
venom had zero references to spider-man
right venom couldn't have the white logo
is his story was completely divorced
from the entire MCU he didn't like deny
that there were Avengers or anything
like that but he also didn't acknowledge
that there were Avengers or spider-man
or anything like that whereas like Oh
Morbius that also exists in this kind of
bump see the Spider Man something
universe Sony Pictures Universal okay
yeah yeah yes right like oh now it's
it's gonna have some connection right to
a totally a Marvel produced spider-man
movie which we already saw right in the
background we already mentioned that
there's a Spider Man poster on the wall
the Morbius runs by and now with this so
it's like it does seem like their
universes are having much more overlap
going forward than they did previously
so that's that's a thick that's a thick
whip that's a big ol thing with that's a
swamp
that's a swamp see yeah cuz that's crazy
the fact that like MCU villains it'd be
like if Thanos showed up in in of
then a movie it's a huge crossover I
mean technically every spider-man movie
it's more of a Sony picture than it is a
Marvel one yes it is co-produced by
marvel it's technically part of the MCU
but Sony's name is on the bottom line of
it they're the first title card you see
so all these actors have contracts with
Sony then all have contracts with Disney
so like yeah they have way greater
control over how those characters are
used so it just people like MJ Ned mr.
Harrington Aunt May they can all
definitely appear in any of these movies
so it's but it's crazy to see a villain
show up I mean especially one you know
that an actor with the stature of
Michael Keaton right if Michael Keaton
were just in were vyas that would be a
big deal right regardless of whether
he's playing an established character or
not I do love I just want to call out
the idea of mr. Harrington showing up in
Morbius like he's definitely getting
like his blood drained but not enough to
die right he'll have it to live and like
limp in to work the next day with like a
bandage on his neck tis but a scratch
this will make my wife come back to me
yeah yeah he plays it for sympathy
whatever it takes this is the fight of
our lives life is a precious flower and
we should water it together well and
while we're talking about that Morbius
trailer that was rich with detail that
you broke down really well
there's also there was a leaked like set
photo right of the Daily Bugle with the
headline like where is spider-man right
somebody took and like leaked that you
pointed out that like The Daily Bugle
like kind of thought it's a print
version right it's not this kind of
newly-established
Jay jonah jameson Infowars website yeah
it's the older version yes and so like
that actually is a subtle callback to
the rainy version I mean that's the
craziest thing right like it'd be one
thing if it was another connection to
the MCU the way that like Adrian Toomes
is the fact that it's connecting to a
different past spider-man universe and
that might be the one that Jay jonah
Jameson is running we did another video
breaking down what that could mean if
it's like a different timeline thing if
it means the multiverse were in like a
different universe or if it's just like
the Infowars thing was what he made out
of the ashes at the print version of
haha of The Daily
Google that went out of style he was
kicked out for being too fringe crazy
and then he's like I'll start my own
thing it turns game post-credit yes
maybe I do love the idea that those two
things like coexisting with like a
copyright litigation between them or
something like that I didn't get the
domain name domain name he's got info or
something like that he didn't get the
dirt that's like that's like a tiny
grain that's like a whip that's like a
very yes spindle a little thread could
just be again a little ass Arturo a jug
on film yes yeah we don't know that it
plays a big plot point okay but somebody
that did play a big plot point in that
first venom movie and again that movie
was largely devoid of references to
Spider Man Marvel anything I and of joy
one leg kind of big reference that could
have larger implications going forward
is the dead astronaut at the beginning
right in the spacecraft that brings the
Venom symbiote to Earth right that was
John Jameson three stars old Nate exit
Jameson who in the comics is the son of
gay jonah Jameson so that could be a
villain flip to the spider MCU right the
JK Simmons version we don't know if that
guy has a son who's an astronaut yet
right or could be a whip to kind of the
Ramey verse where we did see Kirsten
Dunst's
MJ dated an astronaut right John Jameson
in the second movie right hell why not
ass whip to both let's triangulate these
whips let some tiny please we need total
opacity by the end right we can't see
through this way I want a good ol net
spiders kitchen supplies a couple ones
from the games and now of course there's
been a lot of spider-man games and they
are often like linked with their most
recent film counterpart right like the
ps2 game was very referential to the Sam
Raimi movies the ps4 game that's the
most recent kind of big one I had a lot
of references to the current MCU
iteration of spider-man right but like a
big one a big connector there to the
animated you know
was you know when they go underground
Aunt May's backyard and kind of
spider-man's bat lair back there and is
a little bat cave we see all the
different spider-man costumes outfits
and one of them is taken from the games
yeah the white logo ps4 one which is a
subtle like art flip from the animated
universe to the games also in that game
spider-man of course can't like attack
civilians because he's a good dude you
know and you can't go full Grand Theft
Auto on anybody but he can't say hello
are civilians and one of his hellos is
finger guns he hey get his finger guns
that's a subtle Raimi script right -
spider-man three's awful dance sequence
yeah and in that ps4 game they have the
sanctum sanctorum they have Avengers
tower they have all kinds of stuff that
connects to the MCU yeah in like the
sanctum sanctorum looks like the current
MCU version yeah it's the same design
and that that same bad dance of course
real quick from spider-man 3 also gets
referenced in into the spider-verse
during the opening like alternate
universe Peter mentioning ok let's not
talk about this too much
speaking of into the spider-verse
another my earth whip there is you've
pointed out that the voice they use for
kind of Uncle Ben in that opening
montage is Cliff Curtis the actor who
played Uncle Ben in the Sam Raimi
spider-man 1 stay power comes great
responsibility
with great power
comes great responsibility yeah they
kind of Marlon Brando does voice right
when you think of that quote you think
of that actor doing it so basically he
is the the Uncle Ben of that world so
that definitely connects the end of the
spider-verse animated with with the
rainy verse for sure especially because
like there are a lot of connections in
spider-verse I'm just gonna go through a
bunch of them real quickly because that
is the movie kind of built on the idea
of Spider versus and references and
things like that so there's a ton but a
lot of them are to the Raimi verse right
in fact like it's alluded to without
directly said that the Peter B Parker
that we spend most of our time with or
the original kind of Peter Parker and
miles is world kind of both of them are
one of them are basically the Tobey
Maguire Peter Parker kind of either the
original spider-man in his universe is
like current Tobey Maguire or like the
Peter B Parker that he befriends right
it might be like an aged up right a
Tobey after we stopped following his
adventures kind of an idea right and so
a few that we see are like that famous
stopping the train with his body we see
the car flying through the restaurant
window from spider-man 2 that's so great
of course I'm slide down kiss we already
mentioned bad dancing we already
mentioned even like the subtle one of
miles when he gets bit by a radioactive
spider in the tunnels he's taking a
photo which is exactly what Tobey
Maguire was doing when the spider bit
him right it's like it's taking it on
his phone versus the camera because of
course 20 years have passed but that's a
subtle reference and I mean this is in a
lot of the comics a lot of the other
things but like you know Winnie webs up
kingpin at the end and leaves him it's
from your friendly neighborhood
spider-man note on him which was what
you know Toby did in that first one and
you know again there are a lot of things
that were like in the comics too but
because Sam Raimi kind of so famously
adapted them first it's hard not to see
the Raimi vers connection there when you
see it like with great power comes great
responsibility which was from the very
first you know spider-man appearance in
a comic but like it became so iconic in
that spider-man 1 movie so those are all
animated twist to the rainy verse and
then maybe the only one because that
rainy verse was kind of the first thing
and so it didn't have anything else to
reference besides the comics right it's
only outward flip would be this Doctor
Strange quote Doctor Strange
it's taken famously in spider-man 2
while Jay jonah Jameson is talking to
Sam Raimi's brother and I cameo
appearance right I do love that James
Gunn and Sam Raimi put their brothers
and in their movies why do I not have a
brother and why is he not a famous
director does have a brother just have a
brother that's that's step one step one
have a brother
step two he has to become a famous
director so like while they're
spitballing in the newsroom what they're
gonna call what becomes Doctor Octopus
right there they're throwing out names
and they throw out like dr. strange J
jonah Jameson says I like it but it's
taken right which acknowledges that
there's a dr. strange in the Sam Raimi
universe that's all we never see him we
don't know anything else right it's just
kind of like a quick joke but now Sam
Raimi's gonna direct dr. strange - yeah
are we gonna get some pay up are we
gonna see the other side of that like
the gravity falls Easter Egg where the
things go through the portal and they
show back up on Rick and Morty we're
gonna see it we're gonna hear an echo of
Jay jonah Jameson saying that through
some portal and then we're gonna hear
that same line come back through I'm
calling it out yeah I mean it's hard
with the current Benedict Cumberbatch
Doctor Strange like to do the math in
your head right like spider-man 2 came
out I think in 2004 so like you know
that would have been like 13 years
before Doctor Strange the mood or you
know something like that so like yeah he
could have been practicing medicine
maybe already and like might be
well-known enough that a random
newspaper editor would know his name
even if you weren't right the sorcerer
supreme yet right he was a renowned
surgeon might know his name right hey
and and we aren't for sure certain if
the rainy movies are set the release
years ago they could be kind of like
what the excellent movies did a not too
distant future
we do know though your post 9/11 because
they cut out that scene and so there it
was sometime after 2001 that's
all we know but it does seem like Sam
Raimi's the type of director that is
gonna use that in some way right and
like might find a way to have fun with
that and so that could be it's a very
thin slip right now but it has the
potential to be a very thick whip right
late to really pull the Sam Raimi movies
into the broader MCU in a way that like
we never would have thought otherwise
possible who knows and then our final
whip this is a giant like a 12 Roper
right this is just like a whip out of
every finger at the same time and that's
just Stanley but he is the connective
tissue between everything right he
appeared in every movie up to endgame so
boom that's already right like dozens of
flips he also appeared in the ps4 game
he's in into the spider-verse he's in
mall rats he gets a visual cameos in the
Netflix shows he's a Deadpool although
all the x-men movies on the x-men movies
I think using the fantastic four movies
as well he's a postal worker yeah yeah
yeah mall rats and then and then he
pulls mall rats into the MCU right cuz
he's reading them all read scripts on
the train and Captain Marvel which just
just would Kevin Smith needed a little
guided missile fan service just for him
right okay does it get enough love
no no that's kind of our final big
netting of swip what I like about this
is there are all these weird
interconnected connections and and they
could build to something right it's
already there if they ever wanted to do
something on the level of live-action
spider-verse the ground works kind of
been laid yeah that that webbing is is
pretty tight if you were to ask me
you're gonna catch all kinds of stuff in
that web that's a dangerous web what a
tangled web we weave
that's a web of life and destiny if I've
ever seen one yeah well some of the
connections are a bit tenuous some of
them are very obvious and very
deliberate that yeah you're right I mean
if they want to do a live-action
spider-verse think they do already have
one yes and people have talked about
even if you want to get inside baseball
right because the end of the spider
verse one was so sick
cessful and venom was surprisingly
successful these kinds of connections
might be easier to do in the future
right Adrian Toomes Michael King might
not be showing up in Morbius if venom
one flopped and people had a lot of
doubt of if these side characters could
support their own movies and like
there's a lot of speculation Tobey
Maguire himself could show up in a
future spider-verse movie or something
like that because again the work is of
such high quality and success well one
of the reasons we're able to see all
these connections is yes we mentioned
before we've been going back through
these Sam Raimi's spider-man movies and
like these movies I had taken a break
from for like 15 years so it's been so
awesome to go back through them and see
like what kind of fun moves are already
being made
unfortunately in spider-man 3 you know
with Sandman with James Franco as the
new Green Goblin with venom like and
with the weird emo Peter Parker it kind
of sullied it for a lot of people but
it's those first two movies really
really solid and one thing we've been
doing is rewatching these with our
discord community that you can access by
becoming a patron of new rock stars at
patreon.com slash new rock stars this
discord is awesome we have a ton of
wonderful people people who have been
asking questions for this show they've
been helping us keep this channel alive
keeping content coming out regularly so
doing these rewatch --is it's been such
a rewarding thing and just watching the
you know the videos that come out on the
channel is you know it's fun and that's
why we're doing it at the end of the day
but like you're really missing out on
the conversation that leads to those
videos if you're not on discord yes so
if you can help us out at any level even
if it's like five bucks a month really
any tier you can get access to our
discord page so check that out
patreon.com/scishow our stars and yeah I
think we're ready to move on to some
bite-sized questions yeah you're you're
biting these questions aren't you okay
yeah I'll take care of oh my god yeah I
got some answers
oh speaking of discord right one of our
favorite patrons that MCU guy maker of
Nick Fury t-shirts he's sent in in the
time between infinity war an endgame
does Stark Industries still exist right
they seem a bit separated from that life
by the time and game rolls around that's
true well in
vitamin far from home Stark Industries
to donate that big check to Aunt May's
homelessness charity and it was signed
by CEO Pepper Potts herself well you
could say oh this is just a check they
had I don't think they would print stark
in just those checks or novelty checks
or just for the show they're there for
the publicity so I don't think they
would go to the trouble of doing that if
the company wasn't still operational
my thinking is that pepper kept this
company alive during the Blitz aiding in
relief efforts like damage control
that's what Stark Industries was
involved with during spider-man
homecoming and she did have that new
armor and in game it's a nod to her
rescue armor in the comics in which
Pepper Potts becomes like an Iron Man
type figure but doing like rescue
humanitarian missions like relief
missions so I think that has been Stark
Industries new stage there they're
applying their technology to
humanitarian missions around the world
obviously the world needs that and more
than anything else that's great and that
makes sense right like kind of the Ark
for Stark right like going from like
weapons maker to like more like
humanitarian was kind of also Tony's arc
and like that that would be a really
cool like corporate story we also got
from Derrick Campbell on Twitter if
Groot is speaking a real language but it
just sounds like I am Groot because of
his tree Anatomy why didn't quills
interpreter implant translate it yeah
this is like the biggest follow-up
question we've had since our Groot
episode a couple months back a lot of
people were asking about this and I'm
sure a lot of people will continually
will because not everyone watches every
second of all of our episodes but I'll
state it here just so I can link it to
people James Gunn has clarified that in
guardians volume 1 Peters implant is not
yet a universal implant and you can see
that in the sand artbooking screen the
thing Universal Translator captain
Marvel's translator in her movie when
she talks to the security guard she
refers to it as Universal Peter quill
has like you know an off brand knock off
one not from like the advanced Kree star
force so it doesn't have the Groot
language programmed into it yet Groot
language is like a rare obscure maybe an
archaic language they don't they don't
have all of it in there but as the
film's progressed and even though
starting the Guardians vol 2 post credit
scene Peter quill can converse with
Groot
he understands him he calls him out on
his swearing and that's according to
James Gunn just by exposure it's
years they've been together so as
they've start to be around each other
you start to like pick up on on
inflection points on nuances on context
and from there they can see the little
variations in the way he says I am Groot
certain emphasises he puts on syllables
and suits and gross and aims and they're
able to see the wide variety of
different language translations there is
just by being around him so he doesn't
have it in his translator implant I also
quick shout out emphasis on the wrong
syllable I first heard that joke in the
trailer for a view from the top which
was a 90s Gwyneth Paltrow Mike Myers
comedy is the window it's assessed the
window you put the wrong emphasis on the
wrong syllable
that's right hurt it that is I remember
that it and it's in the trailer and I'd
only ever seen the trailer I recently
watched the entire movie awful that
might be the only joke in the entire
movie so that that's my anti endorsement
for this episode don't watch a view from
the top okay now we will move on to our
we're just gonna call it the box of
scraps question what you scrapped
because we used to have a box but it's
coming for the box of scraps and our
personal question this week asks what's
the craziest first day on the job you've
ever had well my mind's a short story
but it's it's interesting I think so
when I first moved to Los Angeles and
this was 2007 which was kind of the last
bad recession we had and I moved to LA
and I'm looking for a job and of course
there's a terrible time to be looking
for like a first job out of school and
I'm like applying to everything on
Craigslist and like nobody's calling me
back until I finally get an interview
with a place and they're gonna hire me
and so like like an idiot
I'm just like yeah yeah yeah I like
didn't care what the job was I didn't
like look into it whenever I show up it
was like this guy who's like it was
starting his own social media network
entrepreneur [ __ ] I even get like
foreign business people something like
that so I show up it's in like an office
building in West LA seemed kind of legit
but the first day I get there I realize
I've been hired to run
company first off never had a job before
and then like there are these you didn't
have these like developers working for
him he's like programmers but like I I
like went to lunch with one of the
programmers that first day and he told
me like they were all Malaysian like
young people that like grew up in
Malaysia or whatever we're living here
and the guy basically told me that the
boss was like kind of holding them all
hostage for their work visas like hey
like cuz you know you're very dependent
on your your employer yeah yeah cuz if
you have to go back yeah and so like
they all wanted to be in the US and so
they were kind of like just that maybe
like under under paying them and like
not being very honest with them and like
I quickly like realized like literally
in that first day that like he wasn't
being honest with me and like here
there's all these weird habits like he
could not stop bad-mouthing UCLA he
thought all people that went to the
simple UCLA were losers low class which
is like it was Lane Kiffin later hip and
ran this company yeah I mean it's a
really good school so I quickly realized
it was borderline catfishing this guy
was a total fraud it was like taking
advantage of all these people and so I
immediately started looking for a next
job I got fired the next week I was of
course while at work submitting to other
Craigslist jobs because the place was so
shady and I accidentally submitted to
the same company they're like you just
got your job application for this
company Wow
so he was organized enough to know that
you yeah that's a bummer Zack all those
people were counting on you to keep the
company intact so they would keep their
work visas you could have saved them and
that that company became uber I have a
similar first day on the job story might
one of my first jobs in LA was working
as a CBS page I think I've referenced it
on the show you know you wear the red
blazers and you escort audiences across
TV sets into a live studio audience
and we got it I got that job through a
lot of people that Zack and I know from
our college improv group there was a lot
of us got that job but like my fur
stay on the job they had me go to a
different asset normally we're at the TV
city lot in in Hollywood this one was at
the CBS Radford lot in Studio City so I
was kind of unfamiliar with where to
park
I read the call sheet wrong so I was
like half an hour late and the audience
coordination crew who's working with us
kind of chewed me out and they just
pegged me as like a problem page I'm
like I swear I'm good at my job but like
they're like just go over you have to
like you have to help the other guy
escort the special-needs folks because
they would have to drive them in golf
carts across a lot because they couldn't
walk that distance well there was one
woman who I don't really know but
according to some other pages they said
that she didn't really need the golf
cart she just didn't feel like walking
but she was like able-bodied she was
completely capable of walking around
they saw her walk up but she it wasn't
the distance from the parking lot to
where the audience meet point was
further than the distance to the studio
but anyway I was not driving the golf
cart my my buddy Josh was and he kept
warning her don't lean your leg on on
the on the side gate of the golf cart
because it's not latched that well but
she didn't listen to kept resting her
foot on it and he was going around a
turn you know cuz their golf carts but
he went around the turn she rolled out
of the golf cart
it was on the ground and Josh like hit
the brake was like and the woman was
just like hey I'm dead I'm dying it was
screaming we could all hear her scream
so they said a lot so I run over and
then like the other people the golf cart
got around and all the people are
circling around and there was two lot
security guards who were like because
they were the ones who had to respond
medically so they were trying to move
her out of the area where like cars were
driving through but like they started to
grab like one had to grab her shoulders
want to grab her feet but the other guy
grabbed her feet was like you could take
her feet and then so there's this like
argument between these two security
guards over how to move her
ever forget Jerry O'Connell was walking
up he's like oh what's going on and he
thought it was just like a bunch of fans
who were just standing by his trailers
so he goes over to like greet him
he's like hey hey and he looks down and
sees the woman on the ground she looks
it up and goes ah and he stares back at
her he's like I can't be here and he ran
away I love Yertle suddenly was aware he
did what people to rethink he was
responsible and poor Josh he had the
woman end up suing and he had to like
testify and there's probably some
settlement it's a big mess we still
don't find Jerry O'Connell baby wonder
what Jerry O'Connell had done that
mighty one that was date one that was my
first day on that show on on that shift
it ended up being the show that end up
working on for years actually somehow
the crew of that show forgave me as they
realize there wasn't a freaking idiot
maybe they had completely forgot about
how I showed up late because this whole
thing happened with this woman or Terry
O'Connell man if you ever just want a
crazy life of stories and weird
celebrity meet and greets move to LA
just for a year and work a couple weird
jobs you'll you'll get the boys yeah I
mean up LA has a lot of very low paying
hard jobs that have the one perk of
you're likely to bump into some famous
people all right well that is our show
this week thank you so much for sending
us your questions and wonderful job
off-screen producers at Austin you
nailed it that spider-verse discussion
was riveting and filled with whips that
I will never forget
thank you Eric for Sherpa Sherpa eying
me on this journey to the top of Mount
new rock stars thank you sir big
question were like big mistake
no way not at all and a reminder that
you can ask us any question we went on
our discord server you can become a
discord member by becoming a patron of
new rock stars at patreon.com slash new
rock stars you can also get audio
versions of the show by subscribing to
new rocks there's big question wherever
you get your
Podcast thanks again people who send
questions you can also send us them on
twitter using the hashtag big question
and in tag one of us in it will see it
and you can mail us at our p o-- box you
can follow me on instagram @ EA boss you
can follow that cuddle stem ed z
huddleston on twitter and make sure to
follow new rock stars on all social
media channels subscribe to new rock
stars so you can get updates on all the
stuff that you need to know about thanks
see you next week
[Music]